escribe la ecuación de la función fx que
se grafica a continuación
aquí tenemos esta función periódica que
será un coseno o un seno pero su línea
media o amplitud no es la típica de un
seno o coseno la línea media va a estar
entre el mínimo y el máximo el mínimo se
encuentra cuando es menos 5 aquí el
máximo se encuentra cuando es igual a 1
y la vida y media va a ser la que se
encuentre justo a la mitad de este
intervalo así que tenemos menos 5 y 1
sacamos el promedio 15 es igual a menos
4 nos dividimos entre 2 porque son dos
cantidades y la línea media es igual a
menos 2 se va a encontrar justo acá así
que la dibujamos y ahí está nuestra
línea media claramente esta función se
encuentra desplazada hacia abajo
esto es ye igual a menos 2 esta línea
ahora pensemos en su amplitud que tanto
se aleja la función de la línea media
bueno tenemos aquí nuestra línea media y
para llegar al máximo o un máximo aquí
tuvimos que recorrer 12
tres unidades lo mismo hacia abajo de
aquí al mínimo de la línea media al
mínimo tenemos una unidad dos unidades
tres unidades
así que nuestra amplitud
nuestra amplitud es igual a 3
así que podemos decir que esta función
fx tiene una amplitud igual a tres pero
todavía no sabemos si es un seno un
coseno así que vamos a escribir ambos
vamos a escribir primero que esto es un
goce no con un coeficiente k por equis
más la línea media que ya encontramos
que vale menos dos y ahora escribimos la
otra versión porque puede ser cualquiera
de estas dos hasta el momento
fx igual a la amplitud de tres por el
seno de un coeficiente cada por x más la
amplitud que ya quedamos que es menos
dos como sabemos cuál de éstas
corresponde a la función graficada
veamos el comportamiento de estas
funciones cuando x es igual a 0 en el
primer caso cuando tenemos x igual a
cero vamos a tener el consell o de cero
que sabemos que es igual a 1 todo esto
será igual a 3 en cambio en el segundo
caso cuando x es igual a cero tendremos
el seno de 0 y sabemos que el seno de 0
es igual a 0 por lo tanto todo esto va a
ser igual a cero veamos qué pasa en la
gráfica cuando x es igual a 0
vemos que es igual a menos 2 y de estas
opciones vemos que la única que cumple
con esto es la del seno cuando x es
igual a 0 seno de cero es cero por lo
que sólo nos queda menos dos como
resultado de fx así que esta gráfica es
de una función seno esta otra ya no me
sirve la quito de acá y solo nos resta
encontrar el valor de acá de ese
coeficiente y para esto necesitamos
conocer el periodo de esta función por
conveniencia vamos a elegir este punto
cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a menos
2 y vamos a seguir la curva en este
punto nuestra pendiente es positiva que
se incrementa conforme x se va
incrementando y si continúo así mi ciclo
va a terminar cuando llegue a otro punto
donde jesse igual a menos 2 y mi curva
tenga una pendiente positiva que se
incremente cuando x se vaya
incrementando así que voy a seguir
remarcando todo esto hasta que llegue a
un punto donde se cumpla esto y aquí
tenemos que la curva llega de nuevo al
valor de igual a menos 2 y la pendiente
es positiva así que
y ya cumplimos un ciclo en esta curva
también tuvimos otro punto con un valor
de igual a menos 2 pero aquí la
pendiente era negativa y ese decremento
va conforme x avanzaba así que aquí no
es un fin de ciclo el ciclo termina
cuando tenemos el mismo valor en g y la
misma pendiente en nuestra curva y ahora
si podemos encontrar el periodo si
medimos la distancia en x de este punto
a este otro punto cuanto nos desplazamos
en x en un ciclo aquí empezamos con x
igual a cero y llegamos x igual a 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 mi periodo es de 8 unidades
así que qué coeficiente debemos tener
aquí para que el periodo de todo esto
sea igual a 8
recordemos cuál es el periodo de seno de
x
el periodo de seno de x es 2 pi si se
incrementa el ángulo o se decremento el
ángulo en 2 pirra dianes llegamos al
mismo punto del círculo unitario cuál es
el periodo ahora de seno de cada equis
aquí en nuestro periodo se incrementará
cada vez es así que llegaremos al mismo
punto cada vez es más rápido por lo que
el periodo será uno entre acá de largo
esto es dos pi entre acá noten que
incrementamos el argumento conforme x
aumenta cada vez es por lo que nuestro
periodo será más pequeño nos tomará una
menor distancia para llegar al mismo
punto en el círculo unitario veámoslo de
este modo si queremos decir que dos pin
/ k es igual a 8 cuanto vale que tomamos
el recíproco de ambos lados k entre 2 y
igual a un octavo multiplicamos ambos
lados por 2 pi nos queda acá igualados
pi entre 8 que es lo mismo que esto se
va entre 4 nos queda la función fx igual
a
es por celo de 24 x menos 2 y con eso
terminamos ustedes pueden verificar esto
calculando los puntos principales de la
función y verán que es igual a ésta